Let's say that we wanted to
compute 78 divided by 12.
What would this be?
Pause this video and
try to figure that out.
Well, one way to think about it is,
this is the same thing as 78
divided by 12, heh.
I know when I said it in
English, it sounds the same,
but here, on the right,
I've written it as 78/12,
or 78 divided by 12.
Now, how can we re-express this?
Well, let's think about it.
Is there a multiple of 12 that's near 78
without going above it?
Well, we know that 12 times five is 60,
12 times six is 72,
12 times seven is 84, so
12 times seven is too high,
but we can write this
numerator as, instead of 78,
I can write it as a multiple of 12
plus whatever's left over.
So, 72 plus six, that's
the same thing as 78,
so it's that divided by 12,
and, so, I can write this as,
I can write the 72/12,
so this is equal to 72 over 12
plus six over 12,
plus six over 12 or plus 6/12.
Now, what's 72 over 12?
We know that 72 is the
same thing as six times 12.
So, this is going to be
six times 12 divided by 12,
well, that's just going
to simplify to six,
and then what is six 12ths?
Well, you might recognize
six as half of 12
or you could divide the numerator
and the denominator both by six.
Either way, you are going to get 1/2.
So, you can view this as six plus 1/2
or you could view this as six and a half,
and a lot of times, or as
you get more used to this,
you won't go do all of these steps,
but I want to make sure
you really understand
what's going on.
So, this is the same
thing as six and a half,
and if I wanted to
express that as a decimal,
that's the same thing as six
ones and then how many tenths?
Well, 1/2 is the same thing as 5/10,
so six and 5/10.
So, there you go!
That's one way of trying to compute
what 78 divided by 12 is.
Let's do another example.
Let's say we wanted to compute
what 20 divided by 80 is.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, we could use a similar technique.
We could say, hey, this is
the same thing as 20 80ths,
or we could write 20 the
numerator and 80 the denominator,
so it's the same thing
as 20 divided by 80,
and then we could think about, well,
how can we simplify this fraction,
or re-express it in some way?
Well, let's see.
We can write the numerator as...
We could write this numerator
as equal to one times 20,
and then we could write the
denominator as four times 20,
as four times 20.
And, so, you could just view
this as being equal to 1/4,
this is equal to 1/4,
times 20 over 20.
Times 20 over 20, well, what's 20 over 20?
Well, that's just one.
That's just one, so this
all just becomes 1/4.
Now, how would we express
that as a decimal?
Well, let's see, it's hard to
express 1/4 in terms of tenths
'cause four doesn't divide easily into 10,
but you can express it
in terms of hundredths.
So, 1/4 is the same thing
as 25 over a hundred.
That's the same thing as 25/100.
Lemme write it down here
so that I get more space.
So, 1/4 is the same thing as 25 over 100,
and you could get that by
multiplying the numerator
and the denominator here by 25,
and the reason why I care about hundredths
is we know how to represent
hundredths as decimals.
This is going to be the same
thing as zero ones and 25/100.
And, so, 20 divided by
80 is 0.25, or 25/100.
So, once again, these are
all different strategies
for thinking about how
we can divide numbers
that result in decimals.